now Vladimir gustaluk has lived in Las
Vegas for more than 20 years he keeps in
touch with his parents and sister in
Ukraine they're in High Spirits and
embody the Ukrainian Spirit he says of
willing to suffer to be an independent
country
we all hope that you you the war ends
soon with Ukraine's Victory because this
is the only way more than 300 days since
that conflict began kutsu Luke says
living in Ukraine is getting tougher but
his family has no intentions of leaving
he calls president zielinski's trip
symbolic what Russia has been doing is
attacking the Ukrainian civil
infrastructure there are people lots of
people in Ukraine that would be without
electricity and heat for hours and days
on end in his job as an immigration
lawyer he deals with people from several
backgrounds some of his work includes
helping ukrainians after they have left
the war-torn country I was actually
surprised because I met a lot of people
who were able to to come here during the
war during the war and for instance they
would let their children stay here and
they would go back some of the folks
returning to Ukraine are women who are
taking care of their husbands who had to
stay back and fight kusul look for your
support for his country in America will
Wane though he's thankful for the
Outreach Ukraine will come out
stronger and will prove to the world
that all the help it's receiving is
absolutely the right thing to do
he as an Engaged Ukrainian Community has
emerged in the valley since the word
began with ukrainians helping one
another Kristen